من هنا من الحدود السوريه التركيه حيث
دخلت عبر منفذ باب الحمام مساعدات سعوديه
اغاثيه محمله بمئه واربعه اطنان من كافه
انواع هذه المساعدات التي ستدخل الى داخل
سوريا تحديدا الى المناطق الاكثر ضررا
وهنا نتحدث عن مناطق شمال غربي سوريا عبر
هذه المساعدات التي دخلت نحن نتواجد الان
في الجانب السوري من هذا
المنفذ حيث دخلت فعليا هذه الشاحنات التي
سيتم توزيعها على اقرب منطقه
تعرضت لاكثر ضرر من هذا
الزلزال وجراء هذا الزلزال وهنا نشاهد
اداره جمرك باب الحمام والعلم السوري في
هذا في هذه السياره في هذا المكان المحاذي
او في بدايه هذا المكان في الاراضي
السوريه في الحقيقه عبر
سوريا الذي سيبدا بتوزيع هذه المساعدات
مباشره بعد ان دخلت الاحد عشره شاحنه
محمله بكافه انواع هذه المساعدات قال بان
هذه المساعدات ستوزع في مناطق شمال غربيه
سوريا وتحديدا على اكثر من ما يقارب اثنين
وعشرين منطقه تعرضت لاداره الكبير جدا
جراءه هذا الزلزال وهذه المساعدات
اختير هذا المنفذ لها لان هذا المنفذ هو
الاقرب لهذه
المناطق المتضرره جراء هذا الزلزال كما
قال بان هذه المساعدات هي الاولى من نوعها
الدوليه التي تدخل الى سوريا بعد ان ضربها
الزلزال قبل سته ايام عبد المحسن الحربي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث منفذ باب الحمام
السوري